though you've made lots and lots of
money you do not want to give any of
that to your potential future kids is
that correct yeah I think wealth that is
given is not a gift I think it's a curse
and I think it ends up hurting more
people than it does helping because like
a lot of meaning in life comes from
struggle and work and who we become in
the face of stress and hardship I mean
one of my favorite quotes is the work
works on you more than you work on it to
Rob someone of the ability to have
struggle in their life might rob them
from becoming the person they ultimately
should or would want to become and so I
think if I have the desire to have my
kids become certain types of people then
I want to set up the condition so that
they become that no one's like man I
just want my kid to be rich like no one
thinks that they want their kids to be
good people and so it's like if you want
kids to be good people then set up the
conditions that create a good person and
that doesn't come from Easy times